2021 has been another incredible year
for the switch with nintendo delivering
plenty of quality titles for adults kids
and families alike my son and i have had
a great time with quite a few switch
games this year and today i'll share 10
of my favorites that would make
excellent gifts for your family and
don't worry i'll do a quick recap of all
10 games at the end of the video and
i'll also include links down in the
description below starting off our list
today we have super mario 3d world plus
bowser's fury while i think super mario
odyssey is still the best mario game on
the switch 3d world and bowser's fury
are more enjoyable for the whole family
up to four players can join in on the
fun as mario and his friends make their
way through an isometric 3d world which
has a slightly different camera from the
more traditional 3d mario titles 3d
world is a remake of the 2013 title for
the wii u which was praised for its
level design and gameplay that game
alone is certainly worth it but the
switch remake also includes bowser's
fury a brand new mario platforming
adventure featuring mario and bowser jr
this one can be enjoyed by two players
with one taking control of mario and the
other assisting is bowser jr the
gameplay is based on 3d world's
mechanics but also includes some
elements that are more similar to a game
like mario odyssey and then it also
includes some entirely new elements that
are fairly unique to the mario series
it's not really a long experience but my
son and i had a blast with it and it was
just a totally fresh take on the mario
formula even in 2021 the pokemon series
continues to be incredibly popular for
kids and while a brand new pokemon
experience is on the way next year in
2022 there are still two outstanding
pokemon titles that released this year
that kids would love to find under the
tree new pokemon snap released back at
the end of april as the long-awaited
sequel to an n64 classic the pokemon
snap series is quite different from the
mainline series and instead of having
players catch and battle pokemon they'll
instead be placed in the role of a
photographer who's helping pokemon
researchers there are various tactics
and strategies players will need to lure
pokemon out and get the best photograph
possible all the while taking the
pictures in the pokemon's native
habitats the game takes place in an
on-rails first-person perspective with
the player along for the ride and a
hovercraft there are more than 200
pokemon to photograph but one thing
parents and family should note is that
this is strictly a single player
experience if you're looking for a more
traditional pokemon experience 2021 will
see the release of pokemon brilliant
diamond and shining pearl this is a
remake of the 2006 nintendo ds game
featuring updated graphics and a few new
features as well you pretty much know
exactly what you're getting when it
comes to a mainline pokemon game diamond
and pearl are both quality entries to
the long-standing series and certainly
worth it for die hard fans even more so
if you've never played them before for
any parents who may be confused about
why there are two versions of the game
you don't need to purchase both for
years nintendo has a tradition of
releasing slightly different versions of
what's essentially the same game
starting all the way back with the
original pokemon red and blue it
basically comes down to a few pokemon
that are exclusive to specific versions
of the game including the legendary
pokemon featured on the cover if your
child is a big fan of the series it may
be a good idea to ask if they're wanting
a specific version first the game itself
though is the same experience across
both versions up next we have mario
party superstars now here's one where
you can get the whole family involved
superstars is the latest entry in the
long running series which is a
collection of mario themed mini games
where players earn points to move across
a virtual game board this one features
100 different mini games as well as 5
remade boards from the n64 trilogy of
games if you're looking for something a
little more outside the box than the
classic titles like mario party you
should check out mario kart live home
circuit this isn't your traditional
mario kart title though rather than all
of the action taking place on screen
home circuit is what they call a mixed
reality title which is where kids can
race physical carts throughout your home
on a track that players lay out
themselves each cart comes equipped with
a camera so players on the switch
actually see what their cart sees as
they race through the house and thanks
to a brand new update for mario kart
live multiplayer is now much easier
thanks to split screen in order to enjoy
multiplayer before this update you would
need two carts and also two nintendo
switches now you'll still need that
extra cart but you don't need a second
switch connect it to your tv and then
you'll be able to enjoy split screen
gameplay and both players can see their
carts racing throughout the house again
though you will still need that second
cart you can opt to purchase a mario
version just like the one you already
have or you can purchase the luigi
version instead nintendo also introduced
a new relay race mode which does allow
you to sort of have multiplayer with
just a single cart basically one player
controls the first lap and then they
switch control for the next lap to a
different player basically just taking
turns that being said this is definitely
one of those titles where kids will
enjoy taking turns because the person
not playing can keep track of the
physical cart that's moving throughout
the house now while home circuit may
stretch your budget a bit this next
title is one that can be found for
around 10 or 15 dollars considering it
released back in 2018. it's the
scribblenauts mega pack which includes
two previous scribblenauts games
unlimited and unmasked it's crazy i can
actually remember when the original
scribblemods launched on the nintendo ds
and it just absolutely blew my mind it
was so fun to try and come up with new
ways to solve the game's puzzles if you
aren't familiar with the scribblenauts
series players will control maxwell who
has a magical notebook that lets him
create seemingly any item he wants
players will use the notebook to
generate items into maxwell's world and
help him solve puzzles kids and honestly
adults too will love testing the limits
of the game to see just how far
maxwell's powers can go and what sort of
bizarre items they can create to help
solve the puzzle up next we have another
classic series that saw a new release in
2021 it's mario golf super rush i adored
the mario golf games as a kid so i was
thrilled to see nintendo bring this
popular series back for the switch with
super rush the visuals and mechanics are
as solid as ever and while this version
features new additions like speed golf
and a story adventure mode i still
believe mario golf is a game best
enjoyed with others and in this version
there are several multiplayer modes you
can enjoy with up to four players
locally of course the game supports
online multiplayer as well and while
there are certain parts of this game
that left fans a little bit disappointed
at the end of the day that rock solid
gameplay will keep you coming back for
more especially if you have friends or
family to play with now if you're
looking for something a bit more frantic
and fast paced the whole family can
enjoy concurrently check out overcooked
all you can eat which is a compilation
of both the original overcooked and
overcooked too i must admit i can't
promise this one won't result in some
shouting as you try and coordinate with
your family members to complete the
orders accurately and on time if you've
never played an overcooked game before
it doesn't take long for things to get
ridiculous
and hilarious the premise is simple
prepare food for customers in a given
amount of time the gameplay though not
so simple it'll throw plenty of
obstacles your way that make this much
easier said than done the level shift
change and add new elements as you
progress which only result in more
insane moments with overcooked you'll
probably want to check your competitive
ego at the door and just enjoy the
journey at this point what kid hasn't
heard of or played minecraft but what
about minecraft dungeons this game is a
spin-off to the classic minecraft and
instead of building and mining players
will hack and slash their way through a
minecraft world filled with traps
enemies and puzzles the game is
relatively short but the levels are
procedurally generated which can help
with things not getting stale too
quickly it's admittedly a simple game
but it's fun for kids and also when
families can enjoy together as it
supports up to four player co-op both
local and online this next title
appeared on last year's list but after a
massive update in 2021 animal crossing
new horizons earns another mention this
year as it remains one of the absolute
best switch games for families who
haven't played yet new horizons will
always hold a special place in my heart
given how much it helped my son and i
bond during the crazy year that was
2020. while our playing time has
certainly dwindled since then 2021 has
breathed new life into the game with a
huge dlc update this recent free update
brought back everyone's favorite barista
as brewster and his coffee shop finally
return there are also new items
customization options and numerous
quality of life improvements the update
also brought cooking and farming to the
game plus now players can grow
vegetables and use them to cook brand
new diy recipes now you may have also
heard there's a new paid dlc for animal
crossing called happy home paradise if
you want to add that update this dlc
gives players the chance to build
vacation homes and other buildings for
their villagers i'm also going to have a
video up for the best ps5 games for kids
which you can check out on the left side
of your screen now as always thank you
all so much for watching i'll talk to
you again soon
[Music]